is in gentlemen the thought for the day
my very cautious of people who are
absolutely right especially when they
are vehemently so Michael Palin so let
us in our own manner and practice be
thoughtful mindful and prayerful as we
for the day well whitey God who has
ordained that men shall dwell together
for their good in the life of a
community we pray thy blessing upon all
who are citizens of this town and
district especially the sick and bearing
in mind at this time the leader of the
council councillor Chris eight in
hospital give thy grace to those who
occupy positions of authority as
councilors and officers that they may
fulfill their responsibilities with
wisdom and equity and in the fear of the
Lord may counselors be large in thought
in word indeed
putting aside or pretense prejudice and
hastiness in judgment and putting into
actions their better impulses to be
straightforward and unafraid so grant
the true faith on its dealing and mutual
service may be the standard of our
common life and make us strong to meet
every challenge which the coming days
and months may bring especially in the
decisions that are made and in our
obligations to future generations in the
name of God the Father Son and Holy
Spirit amen thank you
hmm now as one can see we have a very
good audience today welcome to you all
to our deliberations but because of the
numbers we feel it necessary to have
Tony give a information in case of an
emergency
Thank You chairman hopefully we won't
have any emergencies today and
everything will go fine because we have
so many people in here I just thought it
was worth pointing out the exits we've
got exits to either side of the chamber
the route that you came in goes to the
front door we've got exit routes so that
your left-hand side of the chamber
should the fire alarm sound we will sort
of guide you out of the building we
assemble in the carpark by the windmill
so we can check that we've got sort of
everybody safely out hopefully it won't
happen but if it does if you can sort of
work with us up it'd be much appreciated
thank you very much may I just remind
members and certainly members of the
public who speak to speak directly into
the microphone from a short distance
otherwise it will not be picked up on
the recording having said that did you
all hear me at the back yes good thank
you very much so that's it now first
item of apologies I call upon the head
of paid service to report the list of
apologies Thank You chairman we have
apologies from councillors pemberton
Saints and rights the next item on the
agenda is disclosure of interests I now
invite members and officers to make
their declarations of interest to the
meeting you will all see the caution
which is printed on the agenda and I
would ask you to ensure that is not
acknowledged to the full this yes
chairman item 10 bid number 5 I'm a
member of the Ulster Town Council and
I've been advised that I though I can
speak on the issues with regard to the
Greg and support them but I will not be
able to take part in the actual vote
Thank You counsel
bang Thank You chairman likewise of
myself
let's move on to the next item which is
the minutes of the meeting held on the
26th of February and I therefore seek a
proposer and seconder to those minutes
do I have a proposer and seconder
councillor brain and for all let's have
the heads of the ladies yes wasn't you
Molly
councillor Perry good didn't quite see
you
the fact that council of saint is unwell
he has actually had an operation today
on his knee to remove some infection I
have passed a card around for members
and officers to sign with some goodwill
expressions for him to receive that as
soon as possible
and the next announcement was the
Shakespeare birthday celebrations that
lasted for three days from Friday right
until Sunday and had a particular
initiative this year that was the living
statues we had people from Spain from
Poland from Australia actually and one
or two other European countries as well
as well as people from more local areas
it attracted a good crowd without any
doubt over the three days and
particularly on the Sunday when the
weather was remarkably kind to us and it
was well very well done and it is a
national event not one which is local it
is a national if not an international
event and should be a perpetual item in
the Stratford districts calendar the
winner actually for the senior
competition came from brighton and hove
and he had a prize of five thousand
pounds donated by Belle Porter parents
it was a remarkable weekend without any
doubt another item about a retirement of
a member someone who we have all seen
around for quite some time actually
Allen sheepy he previously worked for
the authority from 74 to 2005 which was
a short term of 21 years he came back to
join us in 2006 on a temporary basis
Allen you deserve a good rest now hope
you enjoy it and I hope you enjoy the
many trips to Australia where I know
your family live and I can quite well
imagine you running up and down the
beach there Bondi Beach I think that
it's
we also have a presentation today
- Beverly hemming for 25 years service
to the council certificate will be given
I'm very pleased to do that
I've got it here so I will come down and
[Applause]
another pleasant thing we have today are
two birthdays I do know that ladies
always claim they've never reached the
age of 25 but on this occasion they
haven't and counselor Polly Giles I know
you haven't reached that but happy
birthday to you and also to Penny and O
Donnell you you are here yes happy
birthday to you as well quite an
occasion for us we never have that on it
yeah most most of our members seem to be
born on the 30th of February so they
visit the as you can see we have got a
very good attendance and the first item
on the agenda public participation is
generally limited in time but in the
circumstances will be waived without any
doubt and I hope that fully proficient
conduct of our business that that agenda
item be allowed them allowed so that the
business on the transport strategy can
be considered together and in saying
that there are three items in members of
questions which do relate to the
transport strategy so I want to
amalgamate those with this particular
item on the agenda no complaints you're
all happy Thanks
now I now invite the deputy leader of
the council and the head of patients to
give their announcements Thank You
chairman only one announcement and has
it already been said the leader is
unwell therefore I have stepped in to
undertake some of his appointments I met
with a delegation from China over the
shakespeare birthday weekend both on the
saturday and indeed on the sunday where
they gave us an update of this hanwen
project which is taking place on the
outskirts of fuji city in china where
they wish to replicate
stratford-upon-avon they seem to be
moving ahead very very fast and it is
our intention that the whole project
will be completed and open to the public
in 2020 Thank You mr. Webb Thank You
chairman just one announcement for me
the council became aware of the death of
a residents who happened to be a former
councillor representing the Ulster Ward
from 1986 to 1990 councillor Colborne I
don't know whether any members remember
councillor Colborne but just wanted to
let members know at the side passing
away of councillor Colborne 5 which is
public participation as you know we have
11 questions and that is why I mentioned
earlier 15 minutes is not adequate the
information from the members of the
public is there what I would ask them to
do in come to the dais at the front and
if they do have a supplementary question
to ask it then but only come if you do
have a supplementary question I will go
through the questions which have been
submitted in the order which I have and
the first one is from dr. Petra Geller
dr. Petra Geller thank you I'd like to
thank the council for being proactive on
this issue and one of the
representatives of the three million
advocacy group in more except and we
look forward to liaising with the
council in due course and of course
other stakeholders so thank you
thank you very much
the second question is from mr. Gosling
mr. Gosling sir could you good morning
good afternoon no supplementary
questions and thank you very much and
you've got the reply which you're
satisfied with thank you number three is
mr. bassington-bassington the eastern
relief road is our belief in the
inevitability of massive development
associated with that road and the
council's failure to acknowledge this
possibility
despite its or its total or almost total
funding by developers councillor richard
says in his answer there is no
suggestion at the current time that an
Eastern relief Road will be accompanied
by development if this is the case can
counsel riches please explain why the
council's undertook a range of traffic
modeling tests with exactly this
scenario and it was only when the
eastern relief Road performed so badly
that they switched to the assumption
that there would be no development thank
you so would you like to respond to our
resident thank you miss blessings and as
you've pointed out there is no
allocation of housing to the east of
Stratford and there certainly no room in
our current core strategy for that by
including an Eastern relief Road in our
core strategy now at this stage we're
including a principle for throughout our
core strategy process we undertook a
number of transport assessments that did
model 3 potential routes for an Eastern
relief Road within those numbers we did
include the possibility for future
development in order to future-proof and
to understand how this
any form of road would be impacted by
future development by including the
principle now we're able we as a council
may as the portfolio holder on the
county councillors the Highways
Authority are able to go out to public
sources of funding in order to find a
way in which we can deliver on this road
without the need for any additional
housing so we have that opportunity we
then have we can then lead on a
development and the design of this road
rather than relying on a develop Road in
due course thank you the next question
is by mr. Peregrine do you have a
supplementary sir thank you for the
response councillor Richards the
question really is when will the road
actually transfer from being a private
initiative by Carla which is at the
moment to being a public road and in
other words funded and operated as a
public highway will this be on
completion of the road because you can't
be both at the moment that decision is
to explore County Council ultimately it
will need to be built and delivered and
opened the County Council then decide
when they adopt that road yeah the
County Council seem to indicate but it's
in to indicate us that it will be a
public road once it's completed and
adopted by them but thank you for that
because there has been some confusion
about the status of the road thank you
resident is mr. Grubb thank you sir I
have an ace up supplement and it follows
on from the previous question about the
eastern relief Road why was there is the
exact route both the full and the
partial now currently drawn in in
supplementary documents that were not
available when the full documents were
available for people to go and comment
on during the referendum on this
document would you mind repeating that I
didn't
the question is why was the route which
is drawn on plans for both the full and
the partial route of the Eastern relief
road not available for in full during
the referendum period when we were
voting on the transport strategy and
only appears in supplementary documents
which were only been released recently
and therefore people were not able to
comment on okay thank you the the routes
that you're alluding to were the routes
that we used for the modeling as part of
the 2015 core strategy transport
assessments they have been public since
2015 and public available for comment
next question the next question is from
mr. hollar t'en mr. Roger halogen right
sir good afternoon
I have no supplemental questions that I
asked at all million observation on
council Rich's response he suggested
relates to the southwestern relief Road
on the western religion does not my
questions the counselor were
specifically to try and tease out of
this council its long-term thinking for
the infrastructure of what I referred to
and my question is greater extracted
nothing in his response has addressed
that at all other than to say and to
remind the councillors but no such
thinking appears yet to have taken place
there's a lot of stuff in the public
domain about relief robes that may or
may not be built and all over States the
council is here today it's remind result
of one thing if whatever intercept you
builds will be here when we are all gone
our children will be all gone and our
grandchildren have all gone
so please if you wish to be a footnote
to history please be a footnote to
history of councilor who actually took a
long term view okay nothing in this
right guide suggests you have
[Applause]
mayor just remind our residents that you
know the purpose for supplementary
questions is exactly supplementary
questions even though comments are very
valid and helpful Oh next is Diane
Brennan no supplementary questions right
fine Thank You mr. Brennan yep thank you
for your response councillor Richards it
is under anticipated that the cost of
maintaining the drainage basin will be
built into commuted sum etc if the road
is adopted by Worcester County Council
again like in a lot of the information
we've had as residents and as an action
group there are no figures at all
involved in this right do you have any
idea what the cost of drainage of five
april acres me personally no yeah okay
so there's no response to this thing so
the council do not are not able to
consider the actual cost of of doing
this or this operation nope you doing -
yeah
it's a supplementary question yeah yeah
so so at this stage know very clearly as
we go as with all forms development we
go through a buying process and at that
stage we assess any committed sums that
will be required as a result of
government we will do that at that stage
that will all be conducted in due course
okay thank you right thank you sir mr.
Thomas I believe you're next mr. Richard
Thomas thank you good afternoon my
question related to the road that's
traveling through the shatar either new
shops redevelop which hasn't taken place
yet and the answer is that it's a the
road is to be a 7.3 metre carriageway is
this not a change to the original design
which is purely residential Road and
therefore will it not have a surprising
impact on those people buying houses
along what they thought was an estate
road now I don't believe it's be a
change now you don't mr. Hardwick mr.
Mike Hardwick do you have a
supplementary question mr. Hardwick may
not be here now - mr. Warrender do you
have a supplementary question on you're
not yet all members of the public has
now asked or dealt words or maybe
supplementary questions we now have the
councillors which will have taken from
their question opportunity towards the
end of the agenda
could I ask councillor Giles to be the
first to provide a supplementary
question essentially what your answer
outlines council Richards is that if
this road isn't viable it's going to
mean going back to the drawing board the
consequences will be very significant
doesn't it mean that that makes it more
important to come up with viable
alternatives now rather than waiting
until the consequences are very grave
and with much further down the line
councillor Jones as you know we produced
through core strategy process and
subsequently have produced an
alternatives document that details all
the alternatives that we have considered
this was the most viable and deliverable
if it's not delivered then of course
that does have knock-on effects in terms
of our core strategy our delivery of
housing our five-year housing land
supply it's important that we get this
right in this important it gets
delivered if an alternative is put
forward and I've said this before
another alternative is put forward we
will review it we will consider it but
it has to be deliverable and it has to
be viable fine next oh I've got canceled
of Giles again you're having a good
value it must be you must be celebrating
your birthday oh yeah certainty is so
important for the residents that live on
Ludington Road in terms of what
compensation and recompense may be
available for the potential harms if
this scheme comes to fruition we've
known about this and the potential harms
and consequences for a long time now why
can't a timescale pre-pre be provided I
believe it again time Scott has been
provided we issued a statement about
blight and compensation about a month or
so ago that detailed that the council
continued to look into alternative
options but ultimate there is a legal
mechanism it's the same one that applied
for the a46 when that was built the m-40
when that was built and hs2 when that
gets built we have a legal framework to
in which we work from and that's exactly
where we are with this position thank
you councillor Ralph
okay is this working so yes so it
clearly needs a feasibility study to see
if a south if southern parking light is
needed and could funds be applied for
and as portfolio holder will you do so
thank you if I understand that right you
asked me if I will apply for funds for a
feasibility study absolutely fine with
that yes I'd like to move to agenda item
8 which covers the transport strategy
issue and first of all I'm going to ask
the monitoring officer just to arbline
what procedural niceties have to be
observed mr. Grafton Thank You chairman
I've been asked to say a few words about
the debating rules just before we start
because the rules might not be very
familiar to many of you who are here
today particularly at the back of the
room so I'm just going to rehearse for
members that the main debating rules so
the public did not have a right to speak
during this debate councilors can each
speak for up to five minutes we are
looking forward to a passionate debate
but not one that becomes disrespectful
please counselors can only speak once
unless they are going to speak on an
amendment the proposer of emotion or an
amendment to emotion will set out his or
her case and if not already in writing
the Chairman will require the motion or
the amendment to be in writing he'll the
he or she will then need a seconder for
the debate to then proceed the seconder
can reserve his or her speech to later
on in the debate amendments an amendment
to a motion cannot of course
Gate the motion because you have a right
to vote against the motion directly only
one amendment can be debated at any one
time if there are two councillors that
request a recorded vote
then that's what will happen the
proposer of the first motion has the
final word on any amendment if the vote
on an amendment is carried it replaces
the original motion and at that point
there would be an opportunity to put
forward further amendments and lastly
the Chairman's ruling on points of order
and rules of debate are final when
looking at the recommendations at the
report on page 38 in your agenda if
those are moved as a motion at any time
during the debate the chairman has
indicated that he will want to deal with
each of those motion of those issues
separately thank you it's obviously
complex procedure which statute
determines we have got to follow it's
there for very good purposes we may find
it a bit difficult to always follow it
in detail but there the help will be
forthcoming from the monitoring officer
now I think the discussion is now for
gin yes yes yes yes I now invite council
Richards to introduce the item thank you
chairman members so in front of you in
the pipes in front of you is the final
draft of the joint strat for uneven
transport strategy which if endorsed
today and adopted by the County Council
in Geneva course will become an addendum
to the warwickshire local transport plan
and act as supplementary guidance to
that plan the strategy is a culmination
of many years of work that started with
a series of public meetings hosted by
Nadine's our har we in 2015 and
subsequently continued by my predecessor
myself an officer of both the district
and the County count
one of the most important drivers of
this trust strategy has been the public
opinion poll that was conducted by
Nadine zaharie which among other things
demonstrated that the public's number
one priority was to relieve congestion
in the town and improve our transport
infrastructure this strategy is a
principles-based document there will act
as a framework for the development and
improvement of our transport
infrastructure for the next 15 years it
seeks to outline the key objectives and
policies that both councils can then use
to shape and develop the infrastructure
improvements for the town it was first
made available to the public in February
2015 at a public meeting in the arts
house and immediately following that was
open to the public
for consultation on the whole the
consultation showed that the objectives
and priorities of the strategy were well
supported
however there were three key areas of
concerns expressed by our essence which
I will now outline very briefly the
first of those was the reinstatement of
the Stratford to Honey born line train
line that's been discussed and debated
for a number of years and our
consultation received a huge amount of
letters both in support and in
opposition but the majority were in
support in response to those letters
both councils have set out their
positions more clearly and in particular
we have stressed the need for a further
economic assessment to be undertaken the
second element that generated a
significant number of responses with a
sample of the Southwest relief Road and
Troy it wouldn't have escaped many of
our members notice that this is this
proposal has and continues to attract a
great deal of attention whichever side
of the fence you sit on the proposed
southwest relief Road is enshrined in
our core strategy and subject to a
planning application that I understand
will be submitted imminently so remove
it from the transport strategy at this
stage would put this document at odds
with our core strategy and would
potentially undermine the delivery of
that plan certainly it will open it to
challenge and will will have an impact
on our five-year housing land supply so
in if that is the case and that has
upheld our full-back position in
planning terms is the MPP F which
provides us with little to no control on
the development of our district it is
therefore recommended to be retained
finally the third element of the repair
of the sari finally the third event the
received significant interest was the
principal of the eastern relief Road at
this stage in eastern relief Road has
been included in a strategy for two
primary reasons the first that the
evidence-base which was the transport
assessments conducted as part of the
core strategy evidence base clearly
showed that it along with a southwestern
bypass would create the optimal flow of
traffic through and around the town and
secondly that including the principle of
Anita Mooney frodan strategy would allow
both councils to seek funding for such a
road outside of a developer led
construction whilst three potential
routes were considered in order to
conduct modeling for the transport
assessments no route has been
established nor would one be if we were
to adopt today until further work is
undertaken such work would be subjected
to further public scrutiny and public
consultation by including these from
rethread now that gives us the
opportunity to seek funding that could
bring the road forward without the need
for additional housing that would be a
road that we have full control over the
delivery of by removing it quite simply
we're kicking the can down the road and
leaving ourselves open to the likelihood
of additional housing and a developer
led scheme in the future and we all know
how well that's going down in certain
parts ultimately we now need to decide
if we are prepared to endorse the draft
strategy in doing so you will be
providing me as the portfolio holder and
the County Council as the Highways
Authority the necessary leverage to seek
and obtain appropriate funding from both
private and public sources if we don't
endorse and the County Council don't
adopt the strategy any strength that we
would have will disappear it would be
next to impossible to attain to obtain
any funding for these projects without
some form of development to accompany it
something that will increase congestion
further still and is in no one's best
interests it is imperative therefore
that the council moved to endorse this
plan and enable my colleagues and I to
seek appropriate funding to relieve the
stress on our transport infrastructure
the whole were very kindly on the 23rd
of February last year
printed that over 50 years ago in 1971 I
have a copy here that there was there
were plans for a second river crossing
to the east of Stratford in the town
hall there was also an artist's
representation of a proposed four-lane
additional river crossing again to the
east I have a copy here the leaves of
Stratford that was produced in 1957 and
sponsored by the ministry for Transport
a government-led scheme the then sitting
council turned down these proposals and
since then we have done nothing to
support the increase in the population
and vehicle reliance in this town now is
the time for us to do so we've been
elected to make difficult decisions for
the best of this town and our district
now is your chance to do just that
be brave be bold it may be our last
chance for another 50 years
and with that chairman I would like to
move that we go to the recommendation as
set out in the report I would also like
to request a recorded vote on these on
this recommendation or any amendments
that may be put thank you do we have a
seconder council sir well I think had
his hand up first
not your - Jake - so yeah I'll take each
one separately as advised on
recommendation number one sorry know
that the stratford-on-avon air transport
strategy be added to the list of counsel
plans and strategies within part 3 of
the Constitution to allow the council to
endorse it that has been proposed and
seconded do we have any amendments right
the purpose is to have a recorded vote
on one any discussion on the
recommendation recommendation 1 page 38
of your agenda yes
yes just one so it's been proposing sex
on it yeah perhaps you can do so so for
everybody's benefit if you turn to page
twenty thirty eight of your agenda and
you'll see bold at the bottom two
recommendations to council councillor
Richards has moved both those
recommendations they've been seconded by
Councillor carriage at the back and both
of them have requested a recorded vote
on both matters
the Chairman has just indicated that he
wants to deal with each of those matters
separately one and two and we're at the
moment looking at one only not to or
assured on that suggestion though it's
been at this stage we have no choice but
to vote against this well that's that
may not be a democratic opinion but
there we are
what about it I mean we can take it's
been proposed and seconded perhaps I
better explain what the purpose of
recommendation one is within our
Constitution there's a part which lists
the policies that may be adopted by this
council at the moment this strategy or
any any strategy of this kind is not
contained in the list
what recommendation one seeks to do is
to write into that part of the
Constitution that stratford-upon-avon
transport strategy which will then
enable us to debate it and make
decisions later on in this debate so
it's just to put recommendation one is
simply having the the document admitted
into Council being able to adopt a
strategy not necessarily adopting
strategy being able to the
is a constitutional issue I hope that
satisfied everyone we've had the
recommendation one proposed and seconded
the recorded vote is asked for and I
think we should now proceed to that
recorded vote
Thank You chairman
so what I'll be doing is reading each
councilors name eighths and if you can
indicate whether you're for abstaining
or against the recommendation so if we
start with counselor a concern for
counsel kettle
councillor Adams canceled abarca
counselor bonds counselor brain canceled
Bromwich penciler Cargill counselor
Crump counselor fielding counselor
Voytek counselor frightfully cancel the
Giles counselor get us counselor grey
council Harris abstain thanks Lajos
counselor Jefferson counselor Kendall
counselor carriage counselor Lordan
counselor Mills steamed counselor Morse
counselor O'Donnell counselor organ
counselor Perry counselor pain counselor
Richard's counselor Ritchie's counselor
Ralph counselor very well counselor
Voyager II counselor Williams and that
completes it
yeah so counselors we have 26 in favor
and 7 abstentions though that's
recommendation is carried you've got
that on agenda item 8
we have endorsed the first
recommendation now we have got the
second recommendation which you've all
got you read you've seen and I see
cancer you want to make a statement yes
Thank You chairman I would like to move
replacement recommendation to and there
are copies of it I'll speak to it once
all the copies have been handed out
I'm George
he thinks that some people are confused
about where we are right now this is the
start of the debate to Misrata to assume
you just confirmed yeah yeah wait until
they've had it
you she's going to introduce it
so just to confirm members
we're on we've now had an amendment to
the motion which is worded in on page 38
at recommendation 2 and now we're going
to hear from councilor organ and then
we'll see whether there's a seconder for
that right council organ Thank You
chairman there are many strong feelings
about the proposed transport strategy
and they focus on more than one aspect I
am concerned about the proposed Easterns
relief Road and the lack of phone
proposals on how motor car dependence
can be reduced in this rural district
without having a significant adverse
effect on our residents the proposed
Easterns relief relief road is a poor
example of technical work no information
is provided on what outcomes it will
deliver or what impacts it will have it
is not required to deliver the core
strategy and it should not be included
in the transport strategy the me there
may be a possibility that there might be
a need at a later date but to float an
Eastern relief road now we'll simply
risk unnecessary speculative development
pressure in this area which was firmly
rejected through a public consultation
in 2014 on strategic housing allocations
the time to consider a possible eastern
relief road is at the review of the core
strategy at which time how construct for
District Council and its members make
objective well informed and widely
consulted decisions if the eastern
relief road is already a given crucially
if major development of save three
thousand houses were to be approved as a
direct result of the road and the
sustainability that that road would
offer this would generate approximately
20,000 additional trips per day
on the existing road network through
Stratford undoing for all time any other
improvements that might arise from this
strategy regarding the consultation on
the transport strategy although three
times as many people objected to the
proposed measures which included the
eastern rate relief road as supported it
the objection would probably have been
much greater but for the reassurance is
given at a public meeting attended by
about 200 people in Teddington there are
many people who did not object based on
these assurances at this point I feel I
must challenge the proposed Eastern
relief road 50 odd years ago of course
Peter can be excused as he wasn't there
at the time but although a very very
young teenager I was there is actually a
painting at the Town Hall Peter showed
you the copy of it and it shows the
proposed second river crossing of that
era just about where the Crown Plaza is
now a landing on the tilling Tureaud
side of the river near to the junction
with Locksley Road hardly a proposed
Eastern relief road this proposal was
part of national transport studies back
in the day when all north-south traffic
and all east-west traffic was channeled
through Stratford town after various
reef inks a grander scheme materialized
and the end result was the m-40 which
took away the north-south traffic the
a46 north of Stratford which took away
the east-west traffic and the second
river crossing at seven Meadows Road
there will be a third river crossing
when the south west relief road is
completed Worcester has two crossings
Oxford has three so the Stratford really
need a fourth now about the route of the
proposed eastern relief road we hear
it's written down we hear it's purely
for mob
purposes and there isn't an actual route
but if you look on the map there is very
little options for where it can be
routed and once it's across the river
and lands on the warwick road somewhere
between the welcome hotel and ingen lane
where does the traffic go does it turn
left and go straight on to the jar a
tree in which case what exactly is the
benefit of an Eastern relief road or
does it turn right and go to Warwick
which traffic can already do via the
world's Bourne bypass or does it mean
the requirement for another road to join
up with the a46 near to snitterfield
which can't go across the Welcome Hills
a protective nature reserve so would
have to take a route near to ingen Lane
and undoubtedly even more housing would
be required in that location to pay for
it the inclusion of the eastern relief
road is premature and requires full and
further investigation to completely
understand its impacts and constraints
and I'm asking for your support for this
amendment to remove it from the
transport strategy and demonstrate how
our residents can deal with reduced car
dependency in this rural district with
poor public transport links thank you
[Music]
now in we need a counselor to second the
proposal yes I second this proposal and
I reserve my right to speak at the end
of the debate thank you they're fine
that's good any other counsel want to
contribute yet councillor Perry Thank
You chairman as the ward member of Wales
borer nice I wish to express my deep
concern that the inclusion of the
Eastern relief Road in this transport
strategy which is extremely premature
and inappropriate and in my view should
never have been considered for inclusion
in the first place to include a proposal
for Eastern relief Road in the transport
strategy we have before us today is in
clear contradiction to the core strategy
as there is no reference to the ER
within our adopted plan and there is
clearly no funding available for such a
major infrastructure project any funding
for such infrastructure would require an
element of developer funding and the
core strategy clearly states the wishes
of Stratford district council to protect
the flying functions at walls on
airfield the inclusion of such a project
would just send completely the wrong
message to Gladman developments who
would believe the s DS position and
wells borne airfield had magically just
changed the provision of an Eastern
relief Road would increase the number of
vehicles including hdvs travelling
through the surrounding villages adding
to the existing wrapped runs already
being caused by jlr and later by the
impact of GLH an Eastern relief road
would urbanize the south of
stratford-upon-avon and result in losing
swathe of valuable countryside forever
in the interests of protecting the
residents of Wales born and those in the
surrounding villages it's imperative
that all references to an Eastern relief
Road are taken out of this transport
strategy and
therefore ask birth counselors to
support this amendment Thank You Angela
Vaudrey chairman I am I wish to speak
against this amendment you'll note from
the agenda it talks about a transport
strategy that is for the next 15 to 20
years and as councillor Richards has
very articulated well articulated the
whole point of it has allowed this
council with a headline document to
begin to put together bids to get money
to begin to work through some of these
developments so want to make three
points about this this amendment in my
comments against it the first is we have
probably half the audience today a here
from the southwest relief road group now
their biggest gripe or one of their big
gripes is that actually there is only
one option and it is developer led that
they have no alternative here they keep
asking but there are no alternative
plans to date for them to do it and they
really resent that they resent the fact
that a developer has basically
monopolized the process that ended up
with the proposal that is as we heard
earlier on is due to come before
planning fairly soon the whole point of
a transport strategy in my book is
actually to look at various alternative
routes to look at the funding to look at
where they go to get traffic models done
to look at whether they should go over
the river or to Wells worn or elsewhere
to actually give as Council which had
said residents an opportunity to be
involved in that process which the
residents around the southwest relief
Road have always claimed they were not
involved in that process so this is a
good example of potentially shooting
yourself in the foot by actually
opposing something that might well allow
you albeit there was a chance that by
being there people talked about it but I
have to say if you look at what will
happen over those next 20 years there
will probably two more local plans put
through and it is uncomfortable for some
people but the next local plan that will
be five six seven years away you know it
is going to have to reconsider what
happens at wells born
air-filled and whether that can maintain
its protection as an airfield I have
some doubt about whether that's possible
it's going to look at the impact of what
the University of Warwick is doing on
their wells warm campus and the massive
development there there's going to go
ahead and how that's going to affect
transport it doesn't know life doesn't
start and what will happen is I would
get to say if you if this motion goes
through this amendment goes through is
we will end up with the eastern relief
Road in ten years time in exactly the
same situations as Southwest relief Road
is the second point I want to make is
council been referred to that meeting a
year ago I think it was last April just
before the County elections funny enough
when councilor a second turned up it
almost acted like a white knight there
her speech I have to say it was a
horrible speech from an elected official
because it was she didn't know her
points and it was clearly political if
she kind of claims she was going to
somehow stop this road well the
transport strategy we're debating today
has come from the county so don't kid
yourself that the county is going to be
a white knight it's not going to be a
white knight this is going to go ahead
with God it's not a victory whether this
amendment passes or not today it's kind
of irrelevant because developers will do
what they want to do anyway but you
won't have any alternatives because you
are stuffed with what that developer
will give you the third point I want to
make is that it's the final point when I
had councillor Richards portfolio hold I
made it very clear that I would over my
dead body you'd never get a bridge
between Teddington all the students put
those two villages up well the reality
is it's come back despite all the
comments on the eastern Willy throat and
that option is back on the table again
the county has put it back on the table
again now we could have had a sensible
plan that didn't have it on those people
who live near it between two mouths tone
would have been protected under that
commitment I gave but you know if you
voted against it and the county has
ignored all those views and come back
and put it back in so it's a very
uncomfortable position for you you think
you're gonna get a victory today but
actually I assure you in 10 years time
you will regret it so just say to
councillors think about that when you
are voting about this amendment today
are you really doing them a favor by
supporting this amendment
the wanting to contribute yes counselor
bonds my great concern really is the be
4-6-3 to that we can't get to whichever
row disease
I took the wipe to hospital today
Coventry came down to Clippard Kingdom
Tempest knowing the time and all the
kids are back in school all the way to
town totally blocked Eastern relief
wrote in that respect would have helped
coming back she came back on the bus
supposed to have recorded an hour 20
minutes late because they have to queue
getting into separate so the reason me
for that thing when I was 21 I was
allowed to vote in 1962 at a by-election
laughs as you might that was the first
time I voted no such and the MP said
there should be an Eastern relief Road
and you know what the consumers will it
have an effect on the Monday Davis that
was the great concern than 62 if we
throw that now we were that ready could
any way of illustrating where it goes
where it goes and how it goes so I think
we have government money to look at the
best option
I think it's um it's important to look
at the core strategy in its purpose as
well and its purpose is to improve
traffic flow within the town itself and
it's to these plans will improve traffic
flow on the Birmingham Road and
obviously Clopton Ward being within
within that will improve pollution
levels and with that ward with highest
level of deprivation in the district and
also directly impacts on life expectancy
levels around there as well I think it's
a duty of district to the county
councils to consider health benefits of
improving and reducing traffic flow to
lower emissions for the residents that
work and live in the town it's
inevitable that with their economic
growth comes population growth and
future growth and car ownership has
pointed out the strategy this is one
reason why we I believe it'd be
tantamount to gross negligence to leave
the eastern relief road out of this
document this road potentially would
divert yet more traffic away from the
town centre and some surrounding areas
it's most likely the eastern relief road
will not be built during a lifetime of
the current core strategy however with
the road kept within the strategy more
considered an evidence-based work can
still be considered for impact and
viability assessments governments can
also change in tearing and funding
opportunities may then be missed without
the need to turn to developers to fund
the road with the house building
required to do this in my opinion the
eastern relief road can create
opportunities such as restricting heavy
goods vehicles across clubs and bridge
resulting in an improved air quality was
also dovetailing into Stratford's
neighbourhood plan to take traffic away
from the town centre to create a
so-called pedestrian friendly turn
centre lastly I do not think keeping
this in the strategy would keep all
options open
looking at the facts the evidence one
way or another how the economy will be
affected along with expert studies with
all these factors in mind Council can
still make decision on whether this road
is to be required or not today's vote is
not to build a road it's to keep its
options open and to me that's a
common-sense approach
council little body a bigger pond as I
tell you mr. chairman I have one point
which I'd ask council organ to clarify
and that is in respective paragraph of
page 20 paragraph 4 also includes a
reference to the eastern rate relief
Road I read as it stands impose
restrictions on vehicular access to
Clopton bridge brackets requires
delivery of an Eastern relief Road and
again on page 37 the paragraph 2 and I'm
just flicking through to it so apologize
for the delay again it's exactly the
same point paragraph 2 reads in exactly
the same improved instructional HTV
access over cotton bridge brackets
requires delivery of an Eastern relief
Road if the eastern relief Road has been
removed from 0.2 and 1 respectively for
the sake of clarification it would be
appropriate I believe to have I would
suggest council organ that we will
remove at paragraph 4 and paragraph 2 on
those two pages as well
councillor Giles I've been listening
quite carefully to what's been said by
various councils because I do have mixed
views on this amendment and councillor
Vaudrey is right in the sense that it is
important that the eastern relief Road
or any relief Road or any traffic
solution is part of a transport strategy
so it's not to develop a lead and he's
exactly right that that is where the
problem and the the main problem with
the southwestern relief Road has arisen
however the purpose of a transport
strategy is that it has and commands
essentially the support of the people
that we are imposing it upon and in my
view the case in relation to the eastern
relief Road hasn't been sold or made now
I know that councillor Richards argument
is it's just there as a general
principle and the purpose of that is
that we can see more detail and support
in mice in my view that's that's not
good enough and it doesn't merit
supporting sorry the amendment merits
support because in my view the public
should have been satisfied in this
transport strategy that lots of options
had been looked at they knew
specifically what was on the table they
knew what the various routes were that
were proposed and what the various
benefits and impacts were going to be
and that there was a proper public
consultation possibly and preferably
with referendum to support that that is
when you endorsed a transport strategy
when you actually have all of that
detail you don't just have a general
principle which does potentially open up
problems and dissent and uncertainty and
speculative development applications
riding off the back of it you actually
have a document so in principle I agree
with councillor Vaudrey yes we do want
to transport strategy yes we want to
transport strategy where we take control
of those proposals but this document and
this proposal for the eastern relief
Road isn't right because it hasn't done
what it needs to do
what you set out all of those things so
but actually before this debate
I wasn't sure whether I was going to
support the proposal proposed amendment
by councillor Morgan but now I've
listened and reflected I am in support
of that amendment
Stein over here now so so let's come
from a transport industry background I
cannot stress enough that a lot of
trouble with transport but it's local or
national is not long-term thinking if
you turn now than say we're not going to
include this in our strategy now and it
ends up ten years unlike coming on the
table yet again you don't have as much
influence as if you're preparing in
advance
long term I urge you to seriously think
about that what you don't want a
situation has happened in the past
couple years inside them where we have
planning applications and when it was
brought about traffic issues it was took
a look with congestion basically was to
put put some words sort of used by
member of the planning committee at the
time in adopting it now in this prepared
current form without the amendment that
now allows you a bit more to turn around
so actually let's think about this a
little bit more let's get it right we
can solve problems like helps find
solutions for congestion to make the
environment better that for people but
you have to in the first place not be
thinking five ten years without online
transport you have to think twenty years
down sometimes fifty years down the line
it's counseled by all set proposals for
these sort of things were put forward
years ago and everyone sort of sat there
and still twiddling their thumbs 50 odd
years of this gives a chance now to
actually chairman to say we have a sort
of idea but it's not set in stone but
now we can start climbing it round it if
it becomes an event reality you might
not become an adventurer allottee we
don't know that but there's a good
probability the next 50 years it
probably will be and you argue our
perspective developers come in over the
years next 50 years so let's try now and
sit there and say yeah imprints what we
want this now but we want it on our
terms not anybody else's terms for that
reason I can't support an amendment
I think we have to think long term and
we stay as we are with the current
proposal let's make a contribution
council Rolf you did reserve the right
to speak do you want to exercise it the
vote Europe at stake is above politics
as you're aware castle on organ and I
are not of the same political persuasion
just in case you didn't know but in this
instance we are working together because
we care about the residents from our
adjacent wards and we care about the
long-term impact the eastern belief road
will have on them you should care too
because this could have a long-term
impact on your boards as well this
Stratford transport strategy ends in
2026 our poor plan ends in 2031 the
eastern relief Road is not needed now
there are no proposals in the current
core plan for housing in South East
Stratford therefore until that happens
which will not be for several years
there was no need for an Eastern relief
Road the time to consider any stimuli
throat will be when work is being done
on the new core plan alongside an
updated transport strategy when there'll
be plenty of time to do this work you've
all received emails from individuals and
residence groups detail detailing
reasons for not including leased and
relief read so I'm not going to go and
repeat any of them here now Joseph's
been able to apply for grants to pay for
the ARR well actually that's nonsense
if you read the transport strategy there
are so many other schemes which need
funding which are far more important
than the East and relief Road councillor
riches has just agreed that he's going
to apply for funding for a feasibility
study for a southern park and right we
need to look at lessening the dependence
on the car improving parking improving
cycle networks and getting the southern
Park and Ride these
more important as they will have a major
effect on improving movability around
our town much more so than in eastern
relief road which even a member of the
County Transport group admitted the neck
the network can operate without the
inclusion of the eastern relief road is
too premature and I urge you to support
this proposal thank you
no other cancer which is to address the
issue therefore allows councillor
Richards to give his remarks in summing
up councillor Richards honor on an
amendment because you were the mover of
the original motion you have the last
word before this vote if you want to
to take advantage of the opportunity to
make comment now okay we'll give you two
minutes
I'm going to take a couple of points
there first it's you race Castle Ralph
about funding to suggest it nonsense is
isn't itself nonsense there are funding
pots available for all sorts of
infrastructure the fact that some might
be considered by you to be more
important than others
doesn't mean that the others are
insignificant and aren't going to get
funding so we can look at these as a
whole and apply for funding for them
also I think that was very misleading
and inappropriate I'm actually very
pleased to see that I do have some
supports I'm hoping more than have
spoken about the need for us to be in
control of the delivery of the
infrastructure for this town councillor
John spoke very eloquently about the
frustrations that she's experienced over
the southwest relief Road let's learn
from that you as counselors need to
learn from that we have an opportunity
here to apply for funding to deliver a
piece of infrastructure that does not
require a developer to lead on that
let's seize the opportunity and put that
through I'll leave it at that
thank you I'll ask the monitoring
officer just to give some indication
about the voting implications Thank You
chairman so we're now at the point where
we are going to have a recorded vote for
councillor organs amendment if that is
supported by the vote then it will
replace recommendation two from page 38
and at that point then the Chairman will
invite any other amendments okay if the
vote is defeated then we are left with
recommendation two on page 38 as the
motion okay right we will proceed now to
a recorded vote on councillor organs
amendment thank you chairman as before
I'll ask each councillor whether you are
for the amendments abstaining or against
I starting with councillor Atkinson
councillor kettle
Oh councillor Adams canceled Abarca
canceled abarnes
canceller brain counselor Bromwich
councillor Cargill councillor crumb
councillor fielding councillor Voytek
Council eventually canceled the Giles
councillor get us counselor grey council
Harris for tensile House Council of
Jefferson councillor Kendall councillor
courage Angela Lawton councillor Mills
for councillor Moss counselor O'Donnell
counselor organ councillor Peru
councillor pain councillor Richards
councillor Richie's councillor Ralph
council thorough well counsel of
auditory Chancellor Williams
[Applause]
so counselors there were 22 in favor one
abstention and ten against so that's
carried now the procedure requires that
I invite any other amendments do we have
any other amendments yes I proposed an
amendment which is typed and I would ask
that it's handed round and I was
anticipatory yet to go I couldn't quite
I proposed an amendment it is typed I
would ask that it's handed round and
then I will speak to the proposed
amendment
it goes
that one's carried it then basically
goes together here recommendation at
three she doesn't mean so yes we love
that one let's wrap one plus this is the
three
councillor Giles soldiers keepers just
trying to track something and I propose
this amendment I understand you need a
seconder for that so I asked for a
second
counselors um this amendment proposes
not to remove any reference to a relief
road in the southwest but essentially in
summary what it looks to do is take
reference out to this specific route so
essentially replacing reference to the
Southwest relief wrote Road in its
current route so that is the route which
will go from the Ludington road over to
the ship's turn road and Camden Road and
to replace it with a relief road now the
purpose of that is threefold as you've
heard this document will be used as
supplementary guidance in terms of the
Warwickshire County Council transport
strategy and I do not wish to see this
council endorse the current route now we
know a lot more about what it looks like
the harms that it will perpetrate I
would suggest if this council is seen to
endorse a strategy which contains
reference to this specific route rather
than the concept of a relief Road then
it will be used as a recent endorsement
for this particular route the reason I
don't seek to remove any reference to
the southwest relief Road is because I
don't necessarily agree with but I don't
seek to take on what it said by
councillor Richards that if we remove
any reference to it at all it will
undermine our core strategy and it will
preclude the ability for us to keep
considering the proposals that is
currently on the table all I want to do
is yes okay
leave open the option for the road that
is currently proposed but also leave
open the option for alternative routes
to be considered and this proposal is
designed to encourage Warwickshire
County Council to properly consider the
alternatives as is their duty to do when
any public road is on the table being
proposed and the reason that this
proposal is framed in this way is
because you've heard from me before as
Ward member there is not necessarily
opposition to the principle and the
concept of a relief road in the
southwest of the district it is clear
now that our call strategy envisages
further development in that area the
evidence demonstrates that there will
need to be traffic management strategies
probably in the form of a relief Road to
manage that traffic that is accepted by
me that is accepted by the Stratford
residents group and it is accepted by
towns transport group however your
important council tea on this strategy
is the town transport group and I hope
some of the councillors have had the
opportunity to read what they have said
about this transport strategy and in my
submission there to you that comment
should be given very significant weight
because they point out at the end of
their comments that they are a consul
tea who represent a broad range of
stakeholders they also say that they try
to build consensus rather than plagued
the progress of transport strategies
with unnecessary dissent because they
understand lots of proposals will be
controversial however I must draw to
your attention that this very important
consul T that is the Stratford Town
Transport group currently opposed this
transport strategy in its current form
referring to both the eastern relief
Road and the current route for the
southwest relief road and what they have
said very importantly in their document
is where extra County Council have a
duty to consider the costs and benefits
of the alternatives before the core
strategy proposal is taken forward so
what they are clearly saying is yes it
was perfectly legitimate for the core
strategy to safeguard land in its core
strategy and say this is the possible
route for a road we won't build on it we
won't do anything with that language
interfere with that land so we keep that
option open that is very different from
saying the road has to go there all the
core strategy is saying is that that is
an open option it does not tie the hands
of a planning committee and it does not
tie our hands as a council so now say
that Road must go there and what your
town transport group for
stratford-upon-avon is very clear is
that Warwickshire County Council have a
duty to consider whether that Road on
that line in that exact location is the
right place and my suggestion to you is
that if we endorse without my amendment
this transport strategy that will be
used to suggest during the planning or
any other legal process of 20 seconds
right we have given this route
endorsement so I would ask this
councillors to listen to the people who
are giving you advice you have
Town Transport group board members the
residents directly affected but also
your the o console T's we know from the
report that seems 1 & 6 received more
objection than support
will you please conclude counselor so I
would suggest this modest amendment is a
way it doesn't completely remove the
suggestion it doesn't tie the hands of
bringing forward the current option but
it does allow some further reflection it
encourages the County Council to give
further reflection so I would seek your
support for this amendment as well do we
have anyone else who wishes to speak
councillor Richards Thank You chairman
and councillor jaws lives the fact that
this council by endorsing this strategy
would therefore be endorsing the route
so I'll remind cancers that during the
course strategy process you have already
endorsed to this route broadly the South
Westerley Road is still subject to a
planning application by council John's
refers to alternative routes again I
referred earlier to a document that we
have produced through the core strategy
process and subsequently with all the
alternatives that have been considered
they have to be viable they have to be
deliverable those alternatives have been
considered and the proposal that's been
put forward is the most appropriate of
those alternatives if a further
alternative is put by you or by your
group it will be considered that option
was given to you six months ago it still
hasn't been put forward so I would
suggest that there isn't an alternative
that would be either viable or
deliverable
yeah I'd like to speak against this this
amendment this is um it's like a we once
with European negotiations about a
customs union the customs union it's a
very peasant point we've got here in the
core strategy which again I remind all
members the vast majority of us did vote
for which had this outline route in
there was outline planning equivalent
that was in put forward by a planning
inspector they've got the big rubber
stamp we all kind of went there other
like a council Giles did voted against
everything councillor kettle did as well
and I respect their views of voting
against it but we've all kind of been
there already with this one just to say
on the southwest relief Road it won't be
a popular comment but actually when we
went through the the public meeting 14
months ago now the conclusion that both
the county and and we came to was
actually we did make a very big mistake
in the in the in the transport strategy
by actually including the southwest
relief Road in us at all because the
reality is it had already been part of
the local plan and we never really
should have put it through to
consultation because in many ways we
raised the sense that somehow this
wasn't going to come by Carla Holmes in
front of us and a planning committee
weren't going to have to look at it in
light of the fact it's in the local plan
and a route has been marked out there
that actually what we're looking at
there is the nature of yo the viaduct
that goes over the water is it in the
right line is it you know the
technicalities of planning this is going
to come to planning in the
not-too-distant future all we're doing
with this amendment again if I may say
to credit counselors is somehow giving
some false hope to residents at the back
of this room so this is anyway this
amendment is anyway meaningful it is not
meaningful it is a peasant amendment and
really we should just dismiss it now and
be very clear with residents about where
we are and that it is that planning
meeting and if it ever go if it gets
defeated at planning you'll know go to
inspector it is those routes you have to
try and either amend or tailor it or
oppose it this amendment does nothing
today I'm afraid to say and we should
not waste time with it and we should
vote it down
any other any other comment no no just
before we decide to take the vote I
realize the monitoring officer to
explain what the procedural implications
are oh oh sorry I didn't see your hand
counselor frenzy did you say you wanted
to speak yes it's all nature actually I
find much in the transport strategy to
support but it's at the very highest
level and reads very much as a wish list
of you know better cycling better Park
and widens etc it's a list residents of
the town have talked about for decades
and it but it's good to see it in one
document the floor for me is the detail
which comes forward with the
particularly the Southwest relief Road
as we referred to before in the
discussion on the eastern relief road
residents feel as if they have not been
properly consulted and actually would
want to see their feelings recognized
and unpublished and publicly examined
I've always thought to engage residents
in a meaningful way in the planning
process as early as possible as are I
believe early participation often gets
past the kind of difficulties that we
find ourselves in at the moment this
early communication this early
consultation is incredibly difficult
because quite often we as councillors
are told you can't go and say anything
to residents because actually there's
nothing to say yet but we know very well
there are thoughts and ideas swirling
around there are lines on maps and I
often think that a consultation or an
information giving session right at the
very beginning when those lines first
appear would actually go a long way to
help residents understand what is being
proposed I understand that residents as
we've just been said are not opposed to
the new settlement long Mastan indeed
when supported there's a little
opposition to new infrastructure to cope
with government led housing requirements
indeed as already be mentioned the town
has held public meetings to put forward
ideas but it's when it comes to the
detail that we actually have the
difficulties and as I said there should
be public consultations for the whole
town to look at these solutions when
they come forward this should be
paramount on proposing major
infrastructure projects which will have
life-changing impacts for boodle bad in
the case of a southwest relief Road
residents along Ludington Road are
facing extreme change with a busy road
less than a hundred metres from the back
walls of some of the houses with a
height of 4.5 meters to 6 meters and the
town is facing a large structure across
a water meadow which will change the
aspect from the Western Approaches
forever I firmly believe the transport
strategy which seeks public support
should have a right to proper and fair
compensation for residents whose
lifetime investment not only of money
but of emotions as well will be severely
compromised hs2 is a larger issue
granted but compensation was the first
consideration not the last and I do
think that this is should be part of the
part of the process in the light of this
I think it reasonable reasonable to
propose this small amendment for further
explanation exploration of the alignment
of the road and have proof that this is
the sole solution for the problem
perhaps our MP could ask for public
inquiry for all issues to be discussed
openly and in the public arena I would
ask you to support another counselor no
I can't see any hands this time no so I
will ask the monitoring officer to give
an explanation about the voting
implication just
so just to catch up on where we are
we're now going to be voting for the
amendment put forward by councillor
Giles and councillor fragile II if that
gets support then what happens is it
gets attached to the amendment that
councilor organ put forward and both of
them becomes something called the
substantive motion and at that point we
then ask whether there are any other
amendments and if there aren't then we
vote on that package the organ
Giles stroke fractally package surely we
debate before we vote we can debate this
responsive motion as amended
didn't we we've had the debate on the
amendment yeah
if this gets put if this amendment now
is passed or all fails whatever happens
don't we then vote though we then debate
the substantive motion as amended yeah
you can debate yeah got to that point so
yeah but when we get to that point then
we'll ask whether there any more
amendments if there aren't any more
amendments that as Council of audrey
indicates that can then be a debate on
that that package of measures at which
finally we vote if this if this
amendment from councillor giles and
council fredley fails were then back to
councillor organs amendment which
becomes a substantive amendment and and
again we ask whether there any further
amendments if not there's then a
possibility of a further debate before
the vote okay councillors the same
process of abducting before I will ask
each councillor whether you are for the
amendment abstaining or against started
with councillor Atkinson against
councillor kettle a blue stone
councillor Adams
councillor Barker and Schley Barnes
canceler brain tense lebra Me's penciler
Cargill cancel a Crump Chancellor
fielding pencil Voytek counselor fragile
II cancel the Giles counselor get
essentially grey Chancellor Harris for
Chancellor house came to the Jefferson
counselor Kimball counselor carriage
counselor Lawton Chancellor Mills for
Chancellor Morris counselor O'Donnell
counselor organ Chancellor Perry
counselor pain counselor Richards
counselor riches counselor Ralph
counselor thorough well potential of all
jury and counselor Williams
yeah yeah Thank You counselors so they
were eight supporting that amendment 10
abstentions and 15 against so that
amendment fails obviously it was someone
trained in the legal profession who
introduced this procedure but just to
make absolutely certain we understand
what the next step is the monitoring
officer has currently agreed to outline
it for us so the Chairman will now ask
whether if there are any other
amendments if not then we have us the
substantive motion
the one from councilor organ which
you've already seen if there's some
further debate on that then he'll call
speakers if not then we'll move to the
vote councillor Giles I would ask
councillors to reject this transport
strategy it's a hugely important
document it's quite right that are there
any other amendments no other amendments
are there no other amendments no right
you're back in action substantive motion
well it's not it yes the whole thing
yeah and I would ask councils to reject
this strategy it's an important document
and you seem to be giving being given
the option to accept an imperfect
document or there will be consequences
that we don't have control over our own
strategy there is a third way that we
reject this and actually create a strap
transport strategy which is fit for
purpose as I've alluded to it's clear
that our own Stratford Town Transport
group don't support it in its
current format it is clear that our
community in many respects and many
editions don't respond support it in its
current format in general terms I would
say that the biggest difficulty with
this document is whilst it sets out a
set of aspirations it doesn't in any way
shape or form assess the impact of those
aspirations and that is hugely important
because for example we are told that we
want to now aspire to take our long term
parking or a long stay parking out of
town essentially make it more expensive
in town that's what we will be looking
to put forward when we put forward this
strategy where is the analysis of the
impact that that may have on our
business and our tourism and our
visitors so essentially you are being us
to endorse policies we are being asked
to take forward policies without any
detailed evidence as to what the
positives will be but also what the
negative consequences will be so
essentially the biggest problem with
this strategy is it's a series of aims
without any discussion or evidence about
what are the competing options in order
to bring those aims forward and what is
the evidence which makes those things
buy the positive or negative and a
weighing up we then come on to the
consultation it's a very unambitious
public consultation I know that there's
been talk of we've had a traffic summit
where there are as a small portion at
the end allowed for questions there has
obviously been the opposite and an
opportunity for people to respond online
but if you actually look at what other
districts do they have incredibly
sophisticated consultation processes
which include includes focus groups it
includes detailed sets of worked up
options with all the pros and cons all
of the impacts and it allows the public
to directly feed into that it then
allows for potentially referendums on
certain parts you have much more
sophisticated consultation I would
suggest this document lacks ambition in
terms of innovation and blue sky
thinking for example what consideration
in this document is given to our River
Way it's one of the most interesting and
important features in our district we
there is absolutely no substantive
proposal as to how
we actually use the river to try to
decrease our use of the motorcar we
could have had a proper proper and good
exploration and detailed exploration as
to how that could work there is very
little detail or consideration of that
there is very little consideration of
park-and-ride
prioritization and technology as how to
do that we're told yes we want to do
that but how when is this detail going
to come forward and in my my suggestion
is that actually this document ought to
have that detail we ought not to be
putting in place a series of aspirations
when we don't know whether those are the
right things I would also suggest that
there are contradictions with it within
this document it doesn't sit well read
easily the evidence base if there is one
isn't properly reference or suggested it
is essentially it is not a robust
strategy and what I would suggest
actually is that we need to send a clear
signal to Warwickshire County Council
that unfortunately that work is not good
enough and even if it means some delay
we ought to go back to the drawing board
create a proper document which is fit
for purpose takes on board properly what
our residents want and need from us and
we're not just putting something through
because we're feeling the pressure to
create and put through something if it's
not good enough I don't think it should
have our endorsement attributer I can't
cancel Vaudrey it's been a long debate
so I don't tend to speak for very long
so of you'll be pleased to know I want
to speak obviously in favour of the
transport strategy and the motion as
amended it was 14 months ago that the
traffic summit in the Arts House the sad
art sales declined when we spelt out the
the start of the consultation process in
the months before that there was a lot
of blue sky thinking about what was
possible what was not possible and
actually because we did quite an
extensive consultation process with lots
of groups including the town transport
group three times I think we we actually
took some of that blue sky thinking out
end up with the document we thought was
fit for purpose for a public
consultation that had some quite dynamic
things in it but all
some practical things because you've got
to think what you can deliver kind of
short and then aspirationally long-term
it's taken 14 months since the public
consultation to get the debate in this
chamber despite me on several occasions
what was happening to it it's got fudged
and delayed that long because of the
sensitivity what I want to say is in the
document itself two three four and five
those are the six points two three four
and five either got very little response
or actually quite positive response so
of the six key policy issues there and
surprisingly when I was a portfolio
holder I had to be sort of toe the line
if you like on the strat floor honey
born line and there is a firm policy my
personal view is the sooner we can get
that line in place the better so now a
big fan of it I know councillor Barnes
of doing some workers getting part of it
at least two were the Long Marston
development on that and I was pleased
that on balance the public were in favor
of that so maybe we come off the hedge
and we can find our ask councillor
Richards we can find some money to
actually get on with that grip floor
study and actually work out if there was
a business case for that element the
roads are sensitive honestly people made
Southwest wouldíve people in Ludington
let me look at me anything what a
hierarchal I want this road to go ahead
probably it has to come through planning
and I know people are effective I know
compensation I can ages me a little bit
but actually on the original Eurotunnel
train I was working from MP then it went
through his constituency I have lived
and breathed through the problems you
get with compensation and I do genuinely
sympathize with the fact the process is
horrible and whatever we do as a
district Council it's a government
policy and it is a nightmare I do not
envy you that one of the whole points
around the eastern relief Road was to
try and get some clarity about trying to
build before developer comes and with a
road and they say let's build were
actually we can control whether it does
actually impact anyone or whether we can
minimize that but anyway that's been
take it out the strategy for now
probably until the next local plan so
all I would say is I think as amended I
think it's a shame the members there but
as amendment I would urge everyone in
this chamber to be supporting this
transport strategy and I congratulate
council Richards for
bringing it forward today and putting
forward a a well articulated arguments
in favor of it thank you
um my great concern really hadn't I said
it before is the be four six three two
which will come from the settlement and
all the other houses there's a gun and
the old army camp which Ivan I couldn't
we have not as yet agreed the
improvements for the four hundred houses
County Council came with a fully sort of
thing which the police opposed the
Director of Planning told me off because
it wasn't dangerous five accidents at
one point the police said thirty now as
far as the police are concerned we still
hadn't got the improvements that we need
for safety for the four hundred houses
now although that isn't in the core
strategy that bit between the new road
or roads and the settlement that is an
important factor and there were a number
of other people feel exactly the same as
men she's a dangerous road a week last
about 12 days ago it was closed
twice for accidents for two hours at one
day and Saturday night afterwards she's
a major problem which has gotta be
addressed
I would have preferred at least some
really afraid but that's my personal
opinion because I think that would be
the right place to go for people coming
in disrupted and don't have to go
through the town center they could go
around but that was a personal thing and
I P I accept the motion as it was
approved by the council but all I'm
saying is there was gotta be a letter
work and determination and only help
from the police have we moved forward
with the parish counselor - pretenders
to a situation where we may be able to
have the four hundred so as far as I'm
concerned we've got a
along with this and we'll vote for it
councillor Richards thank you share and
just one last bit very quickly cancer
Jones alluded to the Stratford Transport
group not being in support of this
transport strategy I sit on that
transport group and they've issued me
with a recommendation as has been laid
out by councillor organ and they are
therefore in support they've said
they're in support so with that in mind
and also in the knowledge that through
the consultation the member of public
made their views known and they was
broadly supportive of what we are now
voting on I think we need to move to the
vote and and put this thing through
thank you sorry just a point of order
actually I also sit on that transport
group and one of their recommendations
was exactly what pastor Giles said about
southwestern relief Road yes they have
used to believe red but they also for
Southwest and really thought let's not
forget please not even the one they've
assured me well there seems to be an
element of discord let's say I hope we
can now go to the vote how you're
agreeable on that fine and yes if I
councillors again will be voting on
these what is known as substantive
motion if you can indicate whether you
are for abstaining or against councillor
our concern for councillor kettle
councillor Adams councillor Barker
councillor bonds councillor brain
councillor Bromwich councillor Cargill
councillor Crump cancer the fielding
councillor boutique councillor frankly
Chancellor Giles cancel it gets us
cancel a grey Council Harris against
council house
councillor Jefferson councillor Kendall
councillor courage counselor Lordan
counselor Mills against counselor Morse
canceler O'Donnell counselor organ
Chancellor Perry counselor pain
counselor Richards counselor Ritchie's
counselor Ralph canceled a thorough well
counsel of auditory and Counsell
Williams
so members there were 28 in favor one
abstention and four against so that is
carried the members of the public will
adjourn the meeting for about five
minutes because I would think some of
you may wish to leave but if you want to
stay for the remainder you're very
welcome
item six the Constitution update and the
deputy leader will give comment on this
particular subject Thank You chairman
speaking on behalf of the leader over
the last three or four months a lot of
work has been done on the leaders
statement so it reflects the workings of
the Council on this current day the
process has been through has been agreed
by the executive officers and everyone
else the key thing though is now it
needs to be reflected very much in the
constitution of the council so there is
no confusion therefore I'm asking the
council to support both recommendations
number one to approve the changes are
set out in the appendix wanted report
which was issued separately and then
secondly to authorize a monitoring
officer to amend the Constitution
accordingly
Thank You chairman
item seven notice of motion WCC
children's center counselor Jefferson to
introduce this item Thank You chairman
chairman and members of the council the
notice of motion was considered by the
cabinet on the fifteenth of January a
copy of the minute is shown on page 35
however please note that due to an
administrative error there was some
wording of explanation emitted from the
preamble that wording was the cabinet in
considering the matter and noting that
the proposals had moved on significantly
since the notice of motion was
originally tabled and that revised
proposals were anticipated from the
County Council accordingly it was
resolved that the notion noticed a
motion be rejected in addition this
should have been recorded as a
recommendation from the cabinet council
and therefore it be recommended that no
further action be taken on the notice of
motion thank you just speak yeah just um
just to make a statement on that
Children's Centres in the Stratford
district offer employment supports
health advice child care parenting
health a unified service delivery
designed to prevent isolation and
ultimately to reduce gaps between rich
and poor children which is a growing
body of evidence shows often go on to
define lives the scrapping of children
centers as we see them now have been
imposed by the county council following
savage government cutbacks to its budget
this is a tragedy for our local young
children a new generation coming through
they're not going to get the help they
need to improve the life chances this
motion was an opportunity for district
council to step up to the mark to
support these centers to stay open in
their current format to remain open this
council did not make consideration for
reports from office
nor refer this to the overview of
scrutiny committee for consideration
this I believe that not even to consider
further evidence of the viability of the
motion meant it was a decision of
political will in the longer term the
way we look after our youngest members
of society and their families is just as
important as public health educational
attainment social cohesion and district
well-being this decision locally to
close and reconsider reconfigured
children's centers to deliberately make
them not fit for purpose says just as
much about the kind of structured
district we learn to live in thank you i
seconded the motion mr. chairman happy
that they're not all closed children you
get to school at 4:00 and haven't had
the life that they could have had where
there was families and grandparents
about today my daughter-in-law works in
one is rapid and again I feel that these
centers do need to be kept opening and
I'm pleased that one one is gone I
appreciate but wanna stayed thank you
oh dear sorry to be political because
before I wasn't political but I was at
the county council meeting budget
meeting when it came to Children's
Centres and the labor group unanimously
voted with the Tory group to cut
children sentencing worksheet County
Council I just want that on record thank
you very much mr. Jim sorry because
they're off the strong and some of my
thunder
cuz that was one of the points I was
going to mention as well even though it
was prior to my time becoming a County
cancer just please say that to save them
a 12-month extension had been guaranteed
and alternative provision at the ground
at the Grange in Salem will ensure it
carries on so there are moves afoot to
make sure that the children centers in
our part of the district are being
catered for so good news from that and
again just reinforce the fact that it is
not a part of village food as it
shouldn't be part of a political
decision on this and so our support
cancer off on that one thank you yeah
just to make the point here that
Children's Services we've not revolving
tight around children's centers speaking
from a bit of experience there's
somebody who in October took on
fostering might not nine year old cousin
due to difficult family circumstances I
think we should be assured that out
there there is a lot help and support
for people and I think that it's
important to bear in mind that it's not
just children's centers though beyond
the end oh it's about a full support
service and I have to turn around and
say I commend the social services in
particular watcher County Council who
have certainly given me a lot of
supports I know through talk to other
people through my experiences in the
past few months they to Sagat support so
I think it's important not to focus on a
particular building but also its a
complete network I think that we as a
council should recognize that not just
one bit sex and buildings yes thank you
chair I think one of the key points on
this is that it is actually a county
council responsibility it is not a
District Council responsibility it's
also good that at least four of the
centers in Stratford district are
remaining open not just the one but from
some of the discussions that are we've
had with the County Council I understand
that the service would be better
targeted at the people who really need
the service through outreach more money
and resources will be put into outreach
and the model is still being developed
and will evolve over time so it would
appear to me as though the County
Council are really trying to make the
best of service provision that they can
Thank You chair
yes the monitoring officer would just
like to make an explanation page 36
there is a slight technical error in the
sense that it reads that the notice of
motion be rejected but in fact it it
should have read that it been
recommended to cancel with the notice of
motion be rejected so it is in fact
cabinet recommending to council that the
motion be rejected which brings on the
point that there can be a vote here
should be a vote here on this motion
right I think we ought to follow the
advice given are all in favor of the
motion that the is rejected yep bird
show fans show fans all in favor all in
favor
against I think it's 33 to 1 okay Thank
You members anyway we now turn to item 9
which is the snitterfield Neighborhood
Development that quite a detailed
documentation document in historical and
other terms
Thank You chairman on the 9th of April
2018 the cabinet considered a response
the snitterfield Neighborhood
Development Plan it had already been
through all the stages required of it
and had support right through from the
local population with a ninety four
point two percent yes vote in favor of
the plan there from that basis the
recommendation into the council as
published on page 40 is that one that
the city fielded neighborhood
development plan be made adopted with
immediate effect with a consequence that
it becomes part of the development plan
for shrapnel naval district and to that
Council congratulate such a field
Neighborhood Development Plan team on
their work in the report to be presented
to the council thank you Karen I'm
thrilled this far very clearly in ninety
four point two percent yes votes
demonstrates just how good this plan is
and I'm really pleased that we are
congratulating the development plan on
getting it to this stage thank you
oh sorry let's go again I invite
councilor organiz finance and physical
exercise portfolio elder to introduce
this item colleagues the medium term
financial plan agreed that counsel shows
contributions to reserves in both this
year and the following year thereafter
the situation is reversed the
recommendation is to use some 2.5 or 5
million of these reserves to support the
priorities identified in Appendix 1
these support sounds the council's key
corporate priorities and our one-off
items so on so there are no ongoing
financial pressures into the future
included our funding for additional
small business space loans to support
and help business growth and innovation
wireless broadband for areas that will
not be covered by high-speed broadband
support for Culture and Tourism support
for algebraic Center once it's been
transferred to the council support for a
homelessness hospital Community Safety
support for 2 years
upgrade and modernized CCTV and
provision of a gym at steadly leisure
center the recommendation on page 42 is
to support and make available 2.5 for 5
million for these priorities from the
council's general reserve fund thank you
Thank You chairman chairman we've been
saying for some years now that the
reserves held by this counts that are
too high and I'm glad that the cabinet
has finally recognized this the plan is
to reduce the reserves by two and a half
million pounds worth of spending now I
have no problems with that chairman
though I suspect some residents may be
asking why they've been a succession of
council tax rises when it was clear the
council didn't need the money however as
was pointed out at the cabinet meeting
the list of items on the agenda for
spending it does have the smack of pet
projects from members of the cabinet
although I am glad to see the inclusion
of
funding from promoting Stratford
district on the back of Coventry City of
Culture members may recall that we
proposed this in the budget seven weeks
ago and they decided to vote it down I
hope that members will now recognize the
error of their ways and support it this
second time around chairman as I said I
am concerned that the list is just the
pet schemes of the cabinet at the moment
so at the cabinet meeting I did ask that
all members be allowed to put forward
ideas on spending the two-and-a-half
million pounds we've added a list of our
own in a motion at item 18 I hope the
cabinet will give due consideration to
all ideas put forward by all members
Thank You Jimmy counselor Payne was next
Thank You chairman members at the board
member for the town of Ulster I'm aware
that the indoor sports provision for
Ulster are not up to high standard of
others within a Stratford district
there's a close connection between the
mental and physical health of the
community and the availability and
affordability of first-class indoor or
what the sports facilities I often look
at the excellent sports provisions
provided by strong initial council in
Stratford town chip Stern sow them and
studly I have often dreamt of the day
when my town of Ulster will be able to
share in this exclusive club of district
wild sports provision with the future of
the reg Sports Hall confirmed by this
council I'll see the additional to that
two hundred and fifty thousand pounds
outlined by the spending program as a
welcome investment it demonstrates that
this council recognizes the lead for the
urgent improvements and enhancements of
the current sports facilities in Ulster
therefore I would ask this council to
support bid five that also Greg Center
thank you
Thank You councillor Adams
and Thank You mr. chairman
I'm the adjacent ward member and
represent a community that has no indoor
sporting provision so the great Sports
Hall is essential I've had numerous
complaints to my residents as we have
watched the deterioration of the site
they see this investment is essential my
parish council is councils continually
asked for updates so can I ask for the
tyrants of supporting agreeing to the
additional 250,000 outlined in the
funding of the corporate priorities that
will benefit residents young and old in
and around Ulster and let's hope when
this SDC folder is reprinted which I got
its can meeting this morning that it
will but though it will show five later
centers listed and owned and run by
Stratford District Council Thank You
councillor Cargill Thank You chairman
and projects interesting I must admit I
have got one on there as well I'll come
to that in a moment but thank you I
can't find any of the items have been
listed on the list that are worthy
projects I think they're a great choice
I really do I think they're all good
items and they are in told the whole
district as well very pleased with the
broadband something most discussing at
County this morning it is a big problem
for our rural areas and something
desperately we need to do just out of
interest we are in one day the district
that is in March one of the more exposed
areas as regards disadvantage
disadvantage in in broadband provision
and there's leisure centers well my
colleagues over there I'm said quite
rightly about Ulster Oscar is the second
largest town at the moment and it
deserves a fit for purpose facility
which it doesn't happen I really hope
that the council will make sure that it
is transferred into public ownership as
soon as possible how can well-being
provision again Ulster is a pilot for
with the the NH
the CCG regards to how healthy
well-being for older older people
especially and this is exactly the sort
of thing that we need is good health and
well-being provision and my pet project
is the homeless accommodation which is
absolutely vital and I think that we
should be we are putting up a forward
and I think is an absolutely essential
piece to it I'm quite happy to propose
this to support all of these proposals
here and just a little point the mayor
of Ulster was going to try and come here
today but couldn't make it so I just
wanted to add that particular one but
thank you very much yeah thank you
cancer councillor riches Thank You
chairman
I remember the the cabinet meeting where
we discussed pet projects in the first
place and I wonder whether or not I was
supposed to get offended by that or
whether I was supposed to feel sort of
like the moss was endorsing opposition
and on reflection I was thinking about
how does something become your pet
project and it occurred to me that it
starts off as a small acorn or an idea
or a conversation in the corridor a
conversation in an office somewhere that
then eventually develops into a sizeable
chunk of money being spent on something
to deliver something for the better of
the district so I do have two pet
projects on this list and it seems that
there's a recurring theme so with the
wireless broadband I remember how that
came about in the first place I got more
and more frustrated with the cost of
fibre broadband being run into the
extremities of the district and the
realization that the reality was that
high speed cable broadband was never
going to happen throughout Stratford
district whose cost prohibitive and it's
not the right technology to use anymore
so managed to float a few ideas where
that started to gather some inertia we
approved sorry inertia did
momentum is whatever comes in inertia
anyway
physics aside it gathered some inertia
and we got a 50,000 pound amount
approved at cabinet to go towards the
investigation of wireless broadband
shortly followed up by half a million
pounds which is absolutely fantastic and
trust me from a technical perspective
half a million pound goes an awful long
way when we start talking about wireless
broadband half a million pound does not
go a long way when you start digging up
roads to running cables secondly as part
of my portfolio which is about economic
growth I inherited from my predecessor
venture House which has proved to be a
great test bed for economic development
and small office units that bring people
out of the kitchen or the bedroom into
an office space and allow them to
progress and it crosses that barrier
we've got solid evidence now that there
are there is a high demand for office /
workshop units and by that I mean
they're combined into one there's a high
demand in Coventry specifically for
these and that can't be fulfilled these
units are not available all of a sudden
we're putting forward a plan for half a
million pounds to go towards the
production of these units whether or not
that Stratford District Council that put
these units together or whether or not
we support the scheme or whether or not
it's a joint venture I'm not sure but
the fact is that will add to economic
benefit so yes there are absolutely pet
projects of mine and long that may that
continue and there will be more pet
projects if you want to call it that
that come along in terms of other
members with ideas I totally support
that and I'm really really keen to have
those conversations I'd like to take
credit for the wireless broadband issue
but I'll be more than happy for somebody
else to come forward with that type of
thing I think that's why the cabinet's
there or that's one of the functions of
the cabinet is that members can approach
and come up with ideas and then we can
look at the sort of detailed executive
business case we're doing so in summary
my two items I think are really really
good chairman I'm so I think we should
definitely support those regardless of
anything else but but the corporate
priority in the spending and should go
forward as proposed thank you
yeah I'd look down this list
appears our couplet seem to have
forgotten to go east to the m-40 a
little bit for some projects and ideas
now it would be nice to think the second
largest town in the district would
actually have some sort of benefit from
this money here and we've had a bit of a
lack of consultation with both myself
and councilor country next to me about
potential money we could be put to use
in sell them I'd like to remind
everybody that Ward I represent south
north part of that actually is in the
poorest 5% of the country on that but
nothing in here really does benefit them
at all and these people come up to me
time and time again and say we consider
ourselves the cash cow Stratford
district council we need to get rid of
that misconception so I urge the cabinet
now - yes your projects are good but
let's do some more engagement before
adopting this properly and make sure we
can distribute it properly across the
whole district not too thin small areas
this seems to be very much focused in a
small area and I'd urge the relevant
portfolio holders to sit down and talk
with myself and councillor crumb about
the needs of Southam town as well right
councillor get us was next now thank you
chairman our members
interesting debate up to now
unsurprisingly I'm here to support the
item 5 in this report which relates to
the investment at the Gregg Sports Hall
and I'm going to undertake this from two
directions first of all I had the
pleasure of being the chairman of the
Gregg working group and we're working on
behalf of Ulster Town Council and there
are some financial consequences which
will mean that I'm unable to vote as
with a couple of others at the end of
this the fact is is that the group which
I am chairing at the moment has found
some very interesting ways in which we
can move
the Memorial Hall forwards the sports
facility though adjacent to isn't part
of that same facility and the sports
facility itself is in urgent need of
updating and bringing up to the sort of
standard that members of our community
expect so speaking on behalf of the
mayor of Ulster as well today who asked
me to lend her support to this issue
that she's putting put before you I
would say to the Ulster Greg working
group is firmly in support of any
betterment of the sports and health
well-being offer which is provided that
the the Sports Hall secondly I'm I also
have the pleasure of being the ward
member for kiloton which is the adjacent
Ward
I call it adjacent but all but other
than that it's on the other side of the
road it's actually part of the same
community they've had to put up with
substandard and second-best indoor
sports facilities for years the question
I'm asked on the doorstep continuously
and the parish meetings is when is that
improvement going to take place I see a
light at the end of the tunnel
and the additional 250,000 pounds which
is indicated in this report will enable
Ulster residents to have the same indoor
sporting facilities that all the other
major market towns in this district have
I'd ask you to support the Gregg Sports
Center Thank You councillor Vaudrey
chair I would actually support all the
projects being a pet or otherwise
because one of my gripes about
councillors we just simply don't do
enough it's been obvious for some time
that those reserves are getting
embarrassingly large it's my own fault I
wasn't here at the council that voted
for it but I actually would have opposed
the one percent tax cut I thought it was
ridiculous that given the reserves as
they were that we would actually
increase it and had at that time no
plans to spend the money so I'm glad now
there are projects here but I would make
one request if I made some sure words to
the cabinet - to mr. Buckland that
actually when we look at the budget for
next year can we please have a budget
proposal for debate which actually shows
tax cuts because given our reserves
given that some of these projects
probably won't get done in the next 12
months we're still gonna have a lot of
money sloshing around but I actually
would be in favor because everyone
benefits then not just the best projects
if we actually had a tax cut Thank You
chair councillor fielding with regards
to the broadband wireless roared and I
made inquiries about it and found that
rather than needing the money there is
already an organisation particularly in
my ward which is already dealing with
wireless broadband and is expanding
across and is offering the opportunity
the argument there is do we really need
to have that money sloshing around for
wireless broadband if there are
organizations out there my I also raise
the point of the fact that it seemed
that this one organisation wasn't going
to be giving any wasn't having virtually
a monopoly and therefore should we not
as a district council be looking for
other sources to help with it so noted
camps my house thank you very much
chairman I would just like to say also
that I endorse all of these
recommendations and like councillor
broadly whether they were pet products
or not I think it's an excellent list
and it's across the board one of the
things which I think will help us Adam
is the upgrade of modernisation of CCTV
which is going to help hopefully reduce
the crime wave that we've got at the
moment and it's there a little bit
silently but it is completely out of
data
I think it's been in existence about
20-25 years and with the upgrade that
we're going to have it will fight
helped us very much in the fight against
crime Thank You councillor Richards
realize I didn't assure you have your
hand I didn't but I'll have a go anyway
so yeah broadband first of all the whole
point of this pot is to support the the
groups that you've talked about in the
rollout of their broadband to South them
one of the first rollouts is going to be
an often in Southam and also you talk
about business centers as well you talk
about bit there we talk about business
centers as well and seldom is high up on
that list as it is steadily as as well
as born so there are very much things in
here that will suit you as well so I am
I support what is in this document
Hetal was next Thank You Michelle I'm
moved by the pet projects comment like
some of my colleagues because going
through the list of cabinet members I
can't see any wards which are directly
benefiting from these some proposals but
I'm sure boundaries can be flexible
looking however at the list I will again
support the broadband proposal living in
a village where we are now we have no
access to high-speed broadband we've
been wired up by fibre unfortunately
there aren't enough connections in the
cabinet to enable all those who want
high-speed broadband to connect to the
cabinet so some have got terrific speeds
and some got no speeds at all and I mean
no speeds at all thighs you know that it
just doesn't work so whilst I understand
mr. Fielding's concern about providing
funds towards wireless provision in
rural areas I'm sure miss button won't
be writing out blank cheques to anybody
to enable this to happen but what we
need and what the OSC has been working
for for for some time is the provision
of high-speed broadband across the world
areas of this district we're already
worse or worse off than our fellow
district councils in workshop who have
better connections higher percentage
connections than we do and if we cannot
get hard wired connections as I've
demonstrated in our village then the way
forward is has to be wireless and
anything we can do to speed up the
rollout of high-speed broadband to all
those settlements villages domestic and
businesses who do not have that access
today has to be a good thing so I would
commend that particular aspect of it
although clearly I'm sure there are
benefits more the other areas of
expenditure Thank You chairman these may
or may not be pet projects but what they
are is they're all supporting this
councils corporate priorities the
council from time to time changes its
corporate priorities and it is differing
you're fairly soon the current corporate
priorities are 15 to 18 I think so
everyone should be looking now at what
they want
the council's corporate priorities to be
for the next three years now if we look
at something like the provision of a gym
its deadly leisure center I take I have
to say this is Equalization because not
all areas are treated the same at
different times not so long ago it was a
corporate priority to improve the Leger
provision at chip stone for instance and
a swimming pool was provided and some
time before that it was a priority of
this council to upgrade the leisure
predict provision at Southam which has a
lovely swimming pool and gym facilities
unfortunately Studley doesn't have that
so if you have any of your own pet
projects that you think deserve to be
corporate priorities of this council
bring them forward Thank You councillor
French Li
thank you Joe I just thought you wanted
to briefly comment that I think the are
the big two is really important in the
present sort of climate of our high
streets going under under huge change
and looking at the word innovation
they're really important I think culture
and tourism comes under the same item
that you're actually bringing and
improving the economic vitality of our
of our towns across the district and
very much I'm very supportive of is bid
six of the homelessness hostel and
actually putting some money into that to
make sure that it's going to be fit for
purpose because it is an issue that's
often brought up with me by my residents
that there are issues of particularly in
Stratford but I'm sure of other towns
across the district so very very
supportive of those three thank you - I
just want to pick up on the CCTV steam
upgrade there's no doubt about it the
hardware is reaching and software
reaching the end of the life
the other thing actually is CCTV there
was eight
settlements within the district
including I have to say Sal them it may
well include more as we go through the
sub upgrade because some people have
said can they actually be built aid it's
already proposed that GLH and long
boston are included as they begin to be
built out I have to say that this was a
top priority for public for the public
in one survey that was done it helps
keep people safe and secure and he's got
very very strong support from the place
mister quick one really miss Yemen we
fully support the broadband money or
agriculture and diversification I was
told by three members not to oppose all
step yeah
sorry council Brahmaji can only ask one
question actually I think we've had over
about 51% of members present who've
asked a question we have to go to a vote
to confirm this funding suggestion
because it is a budget issue yeah and a
recorded vote thank gosh we've got to
have a recorded vote so the officers
will go through that routine now but so
that they can perhaps come to an easy
decision anyone not voting in support of
these recommendations now okay now we'll
go to a recorded vote I gather it's
ultra virus so we go to a recorded vote
so members again I'll be calling out
your name and asking you whether you're
for abstaining or against the
recommendation so canceler Atkinson
councillor kettle
councillor Adams tencel abarca Kent
Laban's
Chancellor brain hence lebra Meech
potentially Cargill counselor Crump
who was there please okay
councillor fielding docility and so
fragile ii cancel the giles chance
legatus chancellor grey chancellor
harris abstain transfer house cancel
Jefferson Chancellor Kendal councillor
courage councillor Lawton cancel the
Mills I think is gone councillor Morse
Chancellor Donald's not here
councillor organ thanks Lipari
Chancellor pain councillor Richards
Chancellor Ritchie's councillor Ralph
counselor well potential for jury
counselor Williams so members we have 26
in favor of the recommendation for
abstention so that is carried fine now
members we move on to item 11 which is
minute 876 and motion notice of motion
about air quality control counselor
brain will address this particular item
Thank You chairman thank you the
dispensation to allow me to sit down
today chairman the report that we are
considering today provides a response to
notes the motion that was submitted by
counsels tragedy and wrath in respect of
air quality management areas the motion
was referred to the council's regulatory
and overview scrutiny committees for
consideration who looked at the matter
in some detail and their responses to
detail questions raised within the
motion were considered by the Cabinet on
the 9th of April in considering the
options the cabinet indicate that it
broadly agrees with the suggested
responses in particular consideration
and reposition of the monitoring
equipment measuring point for those
areas where concentration levels were
below the prescribed limit level save
the addition of the detailed action plan
following which it is recommended to the
council but one that the suggestion
response to the specific questions
raised in a notice of motion a state
line in the preamble to this mini-b
agreed as a formal response to the
motion and that a detailed action plan
be prepared by the council in due course
as it is sometimes since the merger was
raised the environmental how-to
reviewed the location of monitoring
choose and continue to monitor air
quality they are currently working with
the planning policy team and the region
or the environmental health body to
produce God's guidance that will improve
air quality chairman I recommend and
move the recommendations on page 2 of
the report speak thank you very pleased
with those somebody please that the
monitoring is going to continue in
certain places not in all places but in
the places that really need to keep the
monitoring going the only thing that
actually asked for it says there's a
detailed action plan to be prepared by
the council in due course I would love
to have a date on that rather than just
do calls
can we have a due date as soon as
possible oh great yes well I'm sure the
Volturi holder will address that in that
case chairman since the portfolio holder
agrees that we needed you date can he
toes when he will tell us our date
sometime in the future it's the
recommendation happy gender item 12
notice of a motion about the housing mix
Council on Lawton
will address this particular issue to
commence Thank You chairman pleased to
present the notice of motion in respect
of housing mix on the 9th of April
camelot considered the points raised in
the motion and in the lights of section
m4 of the supplementary planning
document dealing in part with housing
mix a new approach is that recommended
for adoption as set out on page 54 of
the meeting notes the Infosys chairman
and members is at any proposed deviation
from the adopted housing mix must be
fully justified by applicants going
forward
councillors have asked to approve this
approach which
we included in the supplementary
planning document final version to be
published shortly and chairman and
members I recommend that this proposal
on page 55 is approved on GC thank you
to cancel a lot of that we're broadly
happy with a recommendation on this item
we put this motion forward because we
were getting increasingly concerned with
the way developers were deviating from
the preferred housing mix lay down in
the core strategy and I know that that
was shared quite widely that concern by
many members the draft development
requirements supplementary planning
document contains a list of the
information and evidence developers will
need to provide in the future only time
will tell whether this will be effective
chairman in achieving the council's
preferred mix but in the meantime what's
the replies to the consultation on the
proposals are being considered can I
have an assurance from councilman Lawson
that this council weave will give weight
to the emerging guidance and implement
the new guidelines with immediate effect
thank you mm-hmm would you like to
respond to that councilman thank you
chairman Thank You councillor Morse I
think you've noticed and I'm very
grateful to health help in the last
planning West meeting were you very
eloquently stated that we should
strictly adhere to our housing mix I'd
like to give him that assurance I'm
going forward we don't know how
developers may interpret policy CS 19
but I think with the supplementary
planning guidance now in place and and
its consultation period finished the
will be more wait hopefully and we will
where to address the problem of housing
mix for no more questions oh sorry
counselor kettle I would endorse both
council Norton's
proposals and councillor Moss's comments
I think it's significant that there were
two large applications recently one in
front of planning each
and one in front of planning West both
the significant sized applications and I
think was quite right both house
applications came before committee
because both those committees reinforced
the proposals in front of us by
rejecting a reserved matters application
in planning East in my ward where the
housing mix did not accord with our core
strategy and I have less well informed
about the one in planning West but I
understand that was a that was an
outline application where the developer
wish to have the housing mix determined
upfront and between Council Moss and
council Giles that part of the
application was removed and therefore
the housing mix proposed was not agreed
and I think absolutely we have a housing
mix in the core stretch of a very good
reason and that is to deliver a wide
range of houses not just houses which
maximize the return for developments and
I think we have to stick towards that
because it is the young people who want
to attract into this district which will
take the district forward over the next
5 10 20 years and they need to have
starter homes not palaces and therefore
I think it's absolutely critical that we
support this motion any other
contributor
no so you're all agreed with see the JED
right um 12 yes yes fine now gender item
13 is the delivery of affordable housing
mix options counselor Richards Thank You
members before you should have green
papers today it's a report that was born
out originally from the strategic review
shortly after that a task force or task
group from the OSC and latterly the
affordable housing working group who
were tasked with looking into ways in
which we can influence the delivery
primarily over four of the houses but
houses across the district whilst also
generating an ink
stream for this council to sustain us
into the future following advice from
trounce Hamlin GVA and latterly KPMG we
have had two reports produced this is
the main report which you should all
have a copy of this is a proceed report
that was issued at the training this
morning which I think only four of us
ended up turning up to but you should
should have had an opportunity to read
that now
and ultimately what we're seeking is for
council to approve a set of strategic
objectives which are on the front page
of your green paper I won't go through
them unless you particularly want me to
read them out and secondly to authorize
the cabinet to establish a housing
delivery company now my Stressless the
principle of of establishing that
delivery company subject to the approval
of a further more detailed business case
which includes the government
arrangements of that company and also to
set up any additional companies that may
be required in the delivery of this
housing delivery company I will leave it
at that for German reserve right
speaking unlacing Thank You chairman
chairman I am a support of this proposal
but I want to raise one particular point
yesterday's cabinet meeting on this
subject I pointed out that one of the
reasons we originally raised this matter
was who were keen to find a way for this
council to use developers financial
contributions for off-site housing for
the benefit of this council were rather
than always having to pass these funds
on to a third party and I was assured
yesterday by the portfolio holder that
were the establishment of a housing
company they should be imposter be
possible in future now it's a
complicated area and many pass financial
contributions have had conditions
attached restricting geographically
where one often a financial
contributions be spent and in future
this will probably not be practical to
restrict monies in this way it will
clearly need the rewording of the
planning condition to be attached to
relevant planning decisions
I wonder chairman if we could be told
when the legal department will be able
to complete such a standard condition
and from when this can't
will be entry able to introduce the
specific use of financial contributions
from developers thank you we'd like to
answer that before
yeah report straight
thank you well I fully support this I
think you're aware that I've been
supporting this particular scheme for
many many years now
and as I say as a minimum I hope it can
influence the housing market in the way
that we want it to be but I also think
that potentially could have a
significant impact on on the type of
housing that we want we want for our
residents so I'm not gonna say important
this would just say please support this
because I think it's such a vital scheme
for us thank you council phone tape just
say yeah I support this game and I've
supported it right from its inception
and I think it's really important there
has got cross-party support and it's
really important that Stratford district
council has control over its land and
how it builds on it as well so it's
support about no other questions yeah
yes you'll give some up I don't think as
much me some up just to respond to
yourself council moss I obviously gave
you the the reassurance that the s106
money is a science of affordable housing
could be used by this company obviously
it does require the wording of that to
be appropriate it is dealt with on a
case-by-case basis but we've had
reassurance this morning again from
legal advisors that is possible provided
the wording allows us going forward very
clearly we can't require developers to
make contributions to a company that
doesn't exist so once we've got this set
up once we're in a position to then put
those into us 106's I see no reason why
our legal department come to prepared
for that that very time Thanks who are
the questions fine can we move now on to
agenda item 14 kitchen oh sorry up in
your pardon yes the yeah no no dissent
that's good too gender item 14 the
committee reports
I call upon orders and Standards
Committee report the 26th of March 2018
councillor Barker would you present it
I just refer members of council to the
reports which are on the website and I
have to tell you to do them just to
support the fact that there they are
under note to them thank you and you're
all satisfied good I meant an
appointment committee counselor thorough
well like a chairman I present the
employments and appointments committee
minutes of the meeting of the 10th of
April 2018 you've all read it and are
satisfied over overview and scrutiny
committee 7th of March councillor house
Thank You mr. chairman I have pleasure
in presenting the reports from the
overview and scrutiny committee on the
meeting of the 7th of March 2018 and
those reports are available on the
council's website for inspection and
you've all looked at the quite happy
with them that's great regulatory
committee six of April council Lawton
thank you chair members I'm pleased to
present the the reports from the
regulation committee arm the 6th of
April 2018 the cabinet 12th of March and
the 9th of April councillors farewell
Thank You chairman I have blue green
protecting the Cabinet report and
minutes of the 12th of March and 9th of
April 2018 you we are hoping to have a
short cut on this in the future
but at one time seven and a half
thousand sheets of a4 paper were
produced on exactly the same basis after
we have just had described today next
question 15 12 questions remain
all members asking questions will have
the opportunity to us a 1 supplementary
question can I start with question 1 and
councillor get Asst do you have a
supplementary no supplementary good
counselor Vaudrey do you have a
supplementary I do Thank You chair the
first one is the manifesto so I asked
this question 9 months ago and after say
I was horribly underwhelmed by the
response I'm much happier with the
response this time again as I said
earlier my big thing is I want this
council
to do things to spend money to be out
there kind of actually showing what we
can do I think there is a malaise set in
so I'm glad it's there I did for
everyone's benefit I did warn our leader
that actually nine months ago I would
ask this question again and I would just
stay and maybe counselor farewell you
can let him know when he's hopefully
recovered and back out of hospital but
in another 12 months I'll ask this
question again because I do want us to
be there and it's a political matter but
I suspect all parties if we think about
the manifesto in due course the next
election and I look forward to some very
interesting blueSky thinking in those
manifestos so actually a lot of question
but yes it's it's can you please assure
that councilor st. knows I'm gonna ask
this question to get in 12-ounce time
now you're having another question couch
sorry hey sorry figured button I will
make sure that messages pass through
good question to you can serve Audrey or
you have a supplementary councilors may
remember it was just less than two years
ago I made a very aggressive speech in
this chamber about the police I didn't
think they were doing a very good job in
Stratford at all and a number of you
thought it was inappropriate there's a
time and a place all that kind of usual
nonsense one gets one actually takes a
view about things that we haven't ears
ever since that date the police have got
worse of worse and worse in Stratford
such that it's now recognised because
they are deemed to be requiring
improvement that actually you know even
though independent body the looks of
them recognizes they're not doing a very
good job here we now have murders in
Stratford we've got a bigger problem
we've got all sorts of problems the
original thing came out of our obviously
whether we were tolerant enough for an
EU migrants in this place my question
now - um - councillor Jefferson is if in
a year's time this report comes out
again and says that it requires
improvements will he as a critical
friend to the police actually call for
this Chief Constable to step down
because it is a management issue of the
police it's not working
let's give him a year to get it to turn
round but if he doesn't is councillor
Jefferson going to be strong enough to
tell
staffer district council thinks he
should step down from his job Thank You
councillor Vaudrey it is very
interesting that the police and crime
Commissioner has given the Chief
Constable a clear target the clear aim
that the next report must be good or
better so that I think the police and
crime Commissioner sets something out
very specifically I think at the next
meeting of the police and crime panel in
June I will ask the question if those
aims are not achieved what does the
police and crime Commissioner intend
doing Thank You councillor Vawdrey have
you still got number three was that that
was number three was it bigger pond
councillor France Lee and thank you for
the answer and for the graph I would
have actually quite liked numbers as
well as the graph there are a number of
questions that come to mind on this
graph which I'm not going to go into
discussion at this moment but I would
like to actually talk about the
implications of the graph out of this at
another time councillor Richards okay
the numbers are on the graph
I am happy to talk out it the issues
like this raises in my mind right
question five Council of fragile e do
you have a supplement yes and these
grants are coming from the government
small town little relatively small
although we do have a problem of
homelessness with a relatively small
problem when you look at the larger
urban areas
what is the chances of us getting a
reasonable sum of money when bidding for
these grants because of our our scale
decision given the grant so I can't
really say for certainty what I can say
is the last grant that application we
put together we were awarded the highest
one we've ever received as the Council
of thirteen point four eight million so
we're doing a pretty good job with them
hopefully we'll get something decent
councillor Moore shows us question seven
no sub question a councillor Rolf do
have a supplementary that we have a say
in what is put down on that list who
makes the decision on what is put down
that list and whether when the list is
brought together whether the residents
will be consulted on that list thanks
with their well yeah well while this is
that's a question that's going to take a
bit of answering
it will go through a normal process as
has happened in the past within the
council I think it goes through elf AG
on to cabinet and then to cancel I need
to check that plate for you about the
last bit all I can do is to relay that
information back to the leader a
question and give you a far more
substantive answer outside here which
I'm going to do it well give us two
supplementary him Joe yeah Moore's
question 10
now cancel for check no I'm for 12 thank
you very much now questions to the
leader obviously in the absence of the
leader
we cannot exercise that function but if
you want to ask a question submitted to
the committee team and they will
responds accordingly for one moment
because you and I are the
longest-serving members I think of this
chamber chairman I just wondered if you
would join me in inviting all members
present to say thank you to mr. sheepy
for his very long and valuable service
that he's given to this council
um questions to the leader I know you
said that we can't but I have a kind of
a vague statement I want to make that
involves everybody in the council is
that possible to make as an exception
Thank You chair just say there's a point
of order I'm not I had a normal question
anyone I didn't say but if you got to
make an exception surely I don't
understand I would surprised we're not
making the questions the deputy leader
and in the leaders absolutely stepping
in for him so I do have an old question
I would like to ask if you'll make any
questions it should be for everyone who
has questions sure the problem is the
leader can't respond committee services
have agreed to take your questions on
provide an answer and in the
circumstances of a bit of irritation
over my concession we'll call it a day
on that so right in with your question
and that will then be dealt with
accordingly 17 notice of motion update
for information only now you can read
this without my interpretation you're
all happy we'll just pass it on right
now not a merged notice of motion and
from sorry Kemp's of a4tech and council
volley to propose and second the
following motion notice of motion would
you like to do that please who's going
to start yeah second motion but
presumably you want to you can say
anything yes thank you yep
anti-semitism is a hatred that goes back
centuries culminating in the worst
horrible the Holocaust 2017 saw a record
high of 1382 hate crimes incidents
nationwide the Jewish community were
targeted nearly four times a day this is
up 3% on 2016 which which itself was a
record year he concerns by many in the
Labor Party were eloquently and
powerfully put by two very brave Labour
MPs Luciana Berger and Ruth
Smith that spoke in Parliament they
described a lifetime of anti-semitic
abuse in society as a whole
and were absolutely correct in expecting
the Labour Party to up so to uphold
itself to the highest of standards as an
anti-racist party she said one
anti-semitic in a Labour Party is one
too many
I was also very proud of our Labour MPs
that supported and demonstrated outside
Parliament with a Jewish leadership
Leadership Council and the Board of
Deputies calling for the Labour Party to
tackle anti-semitism it's also really
important to recognize the amazing
contribution that the Jewish community
have made to British life and culture
through people such as suburban cats
Oliver Sacks
Sir Robert Winston Harold Laski Anna
Freud Simon Schama Jonathan Miller Vidal
Sassoon Alan sugar Lou grade and this
goes on in all walks of life British
culture has been enriched by the
contributions made Michael Gove said in
a speech on anti-semitism in 2015 there
is a duty in public life to speak out
and today as counselors we have a duty
to speak out this motion is also there
to give solidarity to our Jewish
community in Stratford district and
beyond but also to send a message to all
racists that enough is enough
they will never win when our community
always commits itself to openness and
tolerance the belief in human equality
and dignity thank you thank you cancel
of Audrey do you wish to yeah I was
delighted a second emotion because I
realise that counsel for checklists you
know can be being political with it I
absolutely have no intention of being
political with it
it's too serious a subject for that I
didn't have one thought I endorse
everything he said I just have one
further comment to make it's really
about social media in the way
intolerance has spiraled over the last
few years because of social media and
it's really I don't know if you like put
a point I don't really understand why
it's a problem a lot of the comments I
can attack why regulate social media
and a lot of the comments are people who
are anonymous and I just wondered if
actually they had to put their name up
there it might actually cut back the
vile abuse that we all probably suffer
from some others but we all probably
suffer from if if that was to be
government policy that would force a
Facebook or whatever to actually say you
had to register your name and I
sometimes have to do the email
it just seems fairly simple you
shouldn't be able to hide behind you
know whatever the boss names are but
just on this particular motion I
delighted the second it and I think
counsel for check should be commended
for putting it forward fine counsel
Morse was first thank you chairman very
briefly we're obviously happy to support
this notion anti-semitism appears to be
an increasing problem and will support
any proposals to help eradicate it as
emotion States anti-semitism a form of
racism something that I'm sure all
members are against as I'm sure over
against all forms of discrimination
whether it be racism sexual orientation
or disability members will recall the
recent problems with the Warwickshire
Pride stall in Stratford which had to
close early because of unacceptable
abuse so problems still clearly exist
it's worth noting chairman that the law
is already in place to combat racism and
discrimination against minorities it's a
matter of evidence and enforcement I
think that public institutions such as
this council have an important role to
play both in setting an example and
being prepared to take action when
discrimination arises and in this
councils Constitution there's a large
section about citizens rights with a
long list of items to which citizens are
entitled it doesn't include anything
about the right not to be discriminated
against and probably because we all take
you for granted but such a fundamental
right doesn't need expressing general it
might be no bad thing next time the
Constitution is revised to make it clear
that this council is opposed to all
forms of discrimination including
anti-semitism and will take action
whenever it's encountered thank you
Council of Giles and
I commend counts the 48 for speaking out
on this issue because it's clear there
are members within his party that
require the support of people like him I
did read a very disturbing article in
the times from John man's daughter which
outlined some very credible death
threats and that and disturbing threats
that her family had received and she did
express the view that in previous years
the Labour leadership had provided her
and her family with with support and
direct contact at the moment that's
missing so it is going to be incumbent
on labour members such as councillor
Wojcik and his local party to make sure
that his party leadership understand the
position that he and his local members
hold on this issue and I'm very happy to
support that motion that he puts forward
very good any other comment councillor
kettle I've been fortunate to live in
Warsaw in Poland for two years and on so
many street corners of the city there is
a plaque on a date with a number of
names written on it some of those names
are clearly of Jewish origin some of
them are of Polish origin where the
religion or the ethnic background is
unidentifiable and I understand exactly
where counsel Morse is coming from that
and his simple and semitism in its own
right is something that we do not wish
to see in this council we do not see in
this country County or anywhere else but
I am concerned that it is a matter it is
not only anti-semitism that we should be
concerned about and councillor Vaudrey
referred earlier on to rising crime
levels quite a lot of that crime level
is of some form of racism against all
sorts of ethnic groups and I think we
need to recognize that this council must
reject all forms of abuse against any
group of identical identifiable people
and whilst I completely support where it
comes
for chicks coming from and I have
witnessed as I said for two years names
on every street corner and have seen the
memorials across the cities of Warsaw
and many other cities where people have
been transported off to the untimely end
but I where it counts the noise is
coming from I think is something we
should consider not just specifically on
the other Semitic side if you don't mind
council forchick I think we have
consider everybody any other
contribution but certainly to me it's
bigotry and then whatever guys bigotry
is it is unacceptable I hope that our
friends from the Stratford held will
make certain that sufficient visibility
is given to this motion which has been
passed by our council today I hope
certainly that that happens
can we now this another notion sorry
someone else technically we've got to
vote on the motion unanimous right yeah
thank you and now there is a another
motion on council mortem Franchini to
propose the and second the following
notice of motion only seconded any
discussion yes
it's got to be referred to cabinet sorry
about that council Cardinal I'm still
learning after about 25 years never mind
urgent business I don't have any new
members have any no we now declare the
meeting closed